il se fait dominer c'est à dire c'est
comme quelqu'un un boxeur qui se promet
un uppercut au premier round
voilà tout à fait après une première
partie où caspar n'ai pas réussi à
trouver l'ouverture mais il se fit
surprendre donc dans la deuxième avec un
vladimir kramnik qui encore une fois la
dominer autant et cette fois mais a
réussi à concrétiser son avantage la
dernière chronique qui semblent mieux
préparés que kasparov dans les
ouvertures ça c'est très très important
puisque avec les noirs pas de problème
il a fait nul face il est là avec les
blancs il a simplement publié garé et
j'ai l'impression qu'il était qu'à 50 %
de son potentiel puisqu'il a joué une
seule variante il a joué une seule
variante et encore une fois il a joué
vite on le répétera jamais acheter tant
que garry kasparov n'arrivera pas à
faire au moins jeu égal au niveau du
temps il va être sous pression
il va être sous pression c'est clair en
tout cas c'était une très belle partie
de vladimir kramnik qu'on va vous
commenter mais peut-être qu'avant on va
regarder quelques images si c'est
possible quelques images du match alors
j'interroge l'ariana le fait donc là ça
c'est la fin du match donc là vladimir
kramnik en train de réfléchir sur la
position finale après la guerre
question est ce assez pour comprendre ce
qui s'est passé va devoir se lever
kasparov abandonne voilà c'était les
dernières images du direct live voilà
kasparov complètement abattu
complètement dans les cordes il est très
mal garé et oui ça fait donc en fait si
le son de la d'événements qui ça se fait
dépasser difficile à notre sens
ray lewis et le son de la dv qui est
passé mais ce n'est pas grave puisque
nous sommes là quand même aux
commentaires voilà kasparov qui s'en va
et les joueurs au fonds sont allés se
préparer pour la conférence de presse
voilà donc cette victoire de vladimir
kramnik alors nous ça nous a surpris
évidemment qui c'était très chaud
c'était juste avoir la limite du temps
on refera jamais à temps que jamais
assez pardon que le temps est important
puisqu'il faut jouer en moins de deux
heures jusqu'au 40e coup et là garry
kasparov abandonnent ou 30e 8e 38e coup
je vais rester de coups à jouer
il fait la gaffe non je crois même qu'il
fait la gaffe au 39e coup après l'échec
de vladimir kramnik tourbe et 6 échecs
kasparov met le doigt sur la mauvaise
case au 39e coûts et sur le 40e coup de
crâne et qu'il abandonne puisqu'il n'y a
plus de solutions il était tout
simplement perdu alors on va voir tout
de suite cette partie là si on peut en
être les chics et voilà nous très belle
donc
défenseurs grünfeld dépenses d'une
faible d'alors qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire exactement au
troisième coup des 5
ça c'est la défense de noël voilà on
pouvait s'attendre éventuellement un fou
g7 de garry kasparov mais qui rentrent
dans sa fameuse estonienne a oublié
qu'il ne joue plus qui joue plus trop
ces dernières années mais il ne l'a pas
joué depuis 12 ans ou 13 ans non
j'exagère un petit peu il a même joué
depuis deux trois ans mais effectivement
la dernière fois qu'il a joué je crois
qu'il avait perdu contre krainik
l'attaquent baïonnette
la taïwanaise contre l'estonienne donc
l'est indienne en ce moment un petit peu
en retrait ne fait plus trop partie du
répertoire de kasparov qui joue plutôt
des gones veulent aider gambie d'âme
quand il veut jouer solide donc là
kasparov en difficulté ne peut plus
jouer son arme qui a auparavant été sans
arme favorite lardière il essaie de
faire nul en fait puisque la grüne fait
lille peut décemment pas espérer gagner
s'est dit très difficile relève est là
qu une femme très difficile de gagner
avec la cruelle d'autant plus que
vladimir kramnik est ce qu'on appelle un
tueur de golf elle c'est à dire qu'il
est extrêmement bien préparé qu'il a
gagné énormément de partie avec ça et
donc effectivement c'est pas le bon
adversaire à choisir quand on veut jouer
une ruelle
alors voilà donc l'appui on prenait 5
calais prenait 5 e 4 là les blancs est
alain force entre deux pions après car
il prend ses trois enfants plus qu'il
faut prononcer trois pions prend pour
prendre les blancs une très jolie sans
trop d'options très fort que les noirs
vont essayer de contre attaquer à
distance avec surtout b le fou g7 en
avoir et puis la dame lecavalier qui
pourra sauter aussi vers le centre donc
il faut absolument que les noirs ne
laisse pas les blancs s'installer
durablement avec ce centre de pions très
fort le centre pion est effectivement
très fort mais les noirs ont tout prévu
pour l'attaqué c'est l'idée de la
défense d'autres et on va voir ici la
thématique fou j'ai sept cavaliers f3c
cinq fours et 3 et la voilà tout de
suite les flashs qui apparaissent qui
éclaire bien ce qui se passe c'est à
dire l'option des 4 et critique il est
sous pression donc par le pion c5 par le
fou g7 par la dame des 8es le fou g4
peut à tout moment de sauter le fou
s'est vite pardon peut sauter sur la
case g4 faire pression sur le cavalier
en f3 qui protège aussi cette case
donc elle directement augmenter la
pression sur ce pion des quatre c'est
toute l'idée de la stratégie des noirs
alors il va devoir une petite
manipulation tout de suite
qui nous aidera à y voir plus clair
c'est celle là donc nous revenons au
début mais c'est pour mieux sauter et
nous voilà donc dans la partie au moment
où nous y étions c'est comme ça crame
nick joue après ses cinq le couffo aux
trois ans la foulée 3 il essaie donc de
consolider son bilan et 4 donc là c'est
vraiment une lutte pour ce pion central
fo à trois sets car si on râle parce
qu'il faut il faut quand même faire très
attention dans cette position là après
ses cinq au septième coup des noirs c5
c'est la grande variante de la défense
de fait c'est la position qui a été joué
on ne compte plus le nombre de parties
kasparov et karpov petrossian flash de
cette position fischer et le coût
principal le coût qui est censée être la
plus ou moins le variant qui posent le
plus de problèmes au noir c'est fou aux
deux et sur petit rock on joue dans
cette position le coutour b1 on laisse
le fou en c1 et on essaie au plus vite
d'évacuer la tour de la grande diagonale
la diagonale du fou que g7
ça c'est ce qui est censé poser des
problèmes et encore les noirs arrivent a
égalisé assez facilement le coup de
crâne nique dans cette position c'est
fou ou 3 lui a une réputation simplement
annulant tu vois la réputation du lot
alors et c'est important au cra munich
joue une variante complètement
secondaire qui n'est pas à la mode
et effectivement c'est surprenant garry
kasparov au début n'a pas compris on le
voyait un peu assommés quand même notre
fou et 3 enfin pas à semaine en tout cas
surpris ne comprenant pas ou cramique
voulait revenir
oui disons qu'elle se disait si ce qu'il
veux pas essayer de gagner
et dans ce cas là qu'est ce que je
voulais faire donc effectivement c'est
psychologiquement peut-être très bien
joué de la part de chroniques ou
psychologiquement souple et comme nous
l'avons pointé dans les commentaires
anglais avec danny king et bien validé
mercredi qui a décidé d'échanger les
dames contre kasparov
exactement c'est la deuxième fois où
donc damas cinq dames d2 tout de suite
les noirs ont l'opportunité d'échanger
les dames en jouant s'éprend des quatre
nuls et blancs reprendrait du plan c et
on échangerait les dames en d2 je crois
que c'est la théorie moderne où la
théorie anciennes je ne sais plus mais
il faut échanger les dames dans cette
position donc hélas le roi reprend 1
s'installant vers le centre avec une
finale
et finalement où les noirs ont une bonne
chance de nul oui finale a priori
complètement égal
je sais que karpov l'avait joué déjà
mais je me rappelle plus exactement des
parties de référence mais je sais
qu'après c'est prendre 4 s'éprend d'un
pro d2 c'est tout simplement voilà c'est
la partie mais revenu c'est kasparov
contre romani chine ou roumanie chine
compte kasparov en tout cas kasparov n'a
pas le savez c'est sûr et il a décidé de
le fou g4 ici qui est bien dans l'esprit
de la grande scène comme on l'a dit tout
à l'heure c'est attaquer le pion des
quatre voilà il augmente la pression sur
des cartes ne peut faire ne pas échanger
les dames il veut peut-être garder la
pression pour voir ce qui va se passer
dans la partie peut-être aussi la peur
de la préparation de travnik et
peut-être kramnik à trouver quelque
chose d idées dans cette dans cette
variante qui est essentielle
peut-être que kasparov ne veut pas jouer
deux finales tout simplement ils
préfèrent regarder toutes les pièces sur
l'échiquier tourbe et un coup joué par
timan dans sa partie contre yb en
dessous qu il ya longtemps
voilà c'est de cela huit ans qui a l'air
très logique à la fois ça enlève la tour
de la pression du fou g7 après des
échanges on sait jamais ce qui peut se
passer donc cette tour est enlevé de la
dgre en diagonale du fou et en même
temps cette tourbe et occupe une colonne
semi ouverte où elle tape sur le pion b
cet ennemi
donc c'est un coût qui est double à
double intérêt à 6 euros par kasparov et
la chronique joue la nouveauté alors
jurieux à six parce que quand même le
plan b c'est est en prison dont 17 étant
prises effectivement on se dit que
surtout reprend bessette gary a vu des
choses il a vu jouer il a vu qu'à
blesser 6 suivi d'un petit rock est une
initiative énorme salaire vrai ça a
l'air d'être une grosse initiative mais
krasniqi a bien analysé cette position
ils jouent sur deux lui tout reprend
bessette et là ça commence à chauffer
pour gagner parce que il est sous
pression il vient de perdre un pion
chronique est très calme et a l'air très
bien préparés chronique si ce qu'il fait
et donc kasparov commence à faire ses
grignote way kasparov commence à faire
ses grimaces et on n'a pas compris le
coup suivant faut dire puisque ensemble
il semblait qu'il n'avait pas il n'était
pas pressé de faire cet échange ils ces
coups suivants fou prend cavaliers 3
alors qu'on a l'impression que ce fou
peut tout le temps s'est changée par ce
cavalier tôt ou tard oui donc pourquoi
le faire maintenant pourquoi le faire
maintenant on ne sait pas c'est un des
mystères et qui subsistent kasparov
atout france 3 apparemment un coup trop
tôt puisque krainik rejoue g pour un f3
maintenant qu'elle sait si c' est la
trame unique joue encore à beaucoup je
crois qu'on peut
dire oui il joue le coup fou c4 quelle
est l'idée de ce coût est bien avoir un
oeil sur le pion à vii ça c'est une
chose mais également chassé sky et c6 en
jouant food et 5 dans certaines
variantes notamment à noter aussi que ce
fou protège vous même temps le pion à
deux écrivains actuellement ça pourra
avoir un petit sens quelque part petit
rock petit rock très bien joué par trame
unique pâtit rock c'est vrai qu'on
n'avait pas prévu dans la cabine de
commentaire pendant le live puisque
cette partie vient d'être jouée on
attend on attendait beaucoup de choses
dans cette position pour ramener mais
pas vraiment petit rock alors qu'en fait
c'est le coup le plus calme qui a le
meilleur effet en fait tout simplement
ouais la tour va venir en jeu va
l'amener à 6,6 et jouer des quatre des
cinq pour commencer voilà ce que s'ils
ont joué avant quand le roi était en vie
il faut prendre ces trois qui gagnaient
la dame avec nuages
maintenant on veut jouer d4 d5 et donc
la position noir sera proprement
catastrophique donc la turquie en 2004
bien joué il faut reprendre avec le pion
est là donc on attendait a priori dame
prend des deux ans au début oui qui
semble logique puisque dame prend des
deux il faut reprendre la dame on prend
le pion au centre et puis avec moi
prenons nos pions avec le camion fou un
peu c'est pas pareil
peut-être avec lecavalier mais en tout
cas ici on suppose qu'après le coup très
fort foulée 4 et bien il y a un énorme
avantage pour les blancs puisque la
paire de fou est proprement très très
très forte ici atteindre à cette date
elle le pion à vii le fou va pouvoir
venir sur la case des cinq loups blancs
c4 donc ici gros avantage pour cramique
kasparov n'a pas joué ça il préfère
pêcher en eaux troubles
c'est à ne pas échanger les dames et
jouer fou prend des quatre tactiquement
ça a l'air de perdre une pièce puissance
10 après dame prend dames on va
envisager ici
cavani prend qu elle y reprend la dame
le fou des caps n'est plus protégé mais
le cavalier à 5 c'est une contre attaque
sur le fouet la tour et surtout
notamment le cavalier va prendre la tour
avec une qualité de plus donc ce n'est
pas possible
travnik ne peut pas jouer comme ça donc
dans cette position
chronique je vous directement d'après fo
prend des claques lecouffe ou des cinq
cirque rabbinique en fait avec son style
très positionnelle mais ces pièces au
bon endroit
voilà le fou
place à une question au centre il
attaque le cavalier c6 qui pour
l'instant tient la position parce que le
cavaly protège à la fois e7 qui est
attaqué par la tour et à s'inquiéter la
dame tout simplement et des cartes et
des quatre aussi donc ce cavalier en
fait le point
je dirais de 'leverage' des voix west a
fait ou alors le point central en tout
cas la position noir et donc ils
attaquent tout simplement ce point et on
voit aussi que la tour à 8 par
transparence est attaqué par ce fou donc
ce fou à l'air idéalement placé sur
cette classe se fait-il idéalement placé
kasparov commence à avoir des problèmes
il est obligé d'aller échanger et dames
enfin on ne sait pas trop ce qu'il peut
faire et ils jouent le coup fous ces
trois pouces et 3 qui était une surprise
on n'attendait pas ce coup là il y avait
l'air fort d'ailleurs qui avait l'air
assez fort parce que ça a provoqué en
tout cas une méditation de chroniques
qui restaient en transe pendant à peu
près 45 minutes ça a été le moment où
chronique des a décidé la suite qu'il
allait donner à son plan canonique est
sorti de sa préparation à ce moment là
il a réfléchi très longtemps
il faut dire que la dame a beaucoup de
cases la caf c2 c'est un des 1 et eu 2 c
les quatre 4 cases principal la case
logic c'est évidemment la case eux deux
où la dame donc ne serait plus du tout
en danger
en revanche vladimir kramnik après une
longue réflexion décide de jouer dames
c'est un s'exposant quelque chose sur la
colonne sait et c'est là que nous sommes
très très surpris que cas ce que garry
kasparov n'ai pas joué le coup tours
assez vite un tour assez vite qui avait
l'air de bain ça laisse éventuellement
pion aux 7000 faut donner le fou des
cinq mois il faut faire faut prendre
cavaliers ça enlève une très belle pièce
de l'ape du côté blanc puisque ce fou a
l'air très bien placé donc peut-être
pour c'était une façon de sacrifier le
pion non mais ici clairement les blancs
noirs épais shufu processus il faut
trouver autre chose peut-être fou mais
si ce qui est possible également mais en
tout cas tour assez vite et bien dans
l'esprit de la grogne faible dans la
mesure où ça ne change pas de pièce ça
conserve tout le potentiel d'attac ça
mais une tour en jeu le roi blanc va
toujours à de faibles donc ça c'était le
coup logique et garry kasparov dans
cette position décide délibérément
d'entrer dans une finale difficile
puisque au lieu de tours à celui qui
conservait un peu d'initiatives qui
conservait beaucoup de choses ils jouent
qu'à et des quatre qui permet à kramnik
une liquidation liquidation
comment provoquer à fond contre
cavaliers [ __ ] on prend un tour
procède pour prendre cette récupère le
pian alors son tour l'avantagé c'est que
le fou des 5
je dirais plutôt gagnant gagne et on
gagne le pion 7 et le fou des cinq est
merveilleux le food et 5 est superbe
il est beaucoup plus fort que le fou des
4 pourquoi et bien simplement parce
qu'il est défendu
il est défendu par un pion il attaque la
torah 8 il attaque le puits
f7 il protège le pion à 2 c'est vrai il
est multiple multifonctionnel se fout
c'est vraiment la pièce qui rayonne le
plus sur l'échiquier
c'est une très très belle pièce garry
kasparov ici a évidemment vu quelque
chose puisque il ne peut pas laisser un
fou ont des cinq est une tour en
recettes l'attaqué c'est trop pour lui
il a vu qu'il pouvait échanger la tour
où il faut donc tour à sept coups cela
dit assez logique qui élimine un peu la
tension entre ce prof à ce moment là
avait l'air assez confiant pour pour
faire mieux donc là un retour pour
prendre un tour très logique fou prend
voilà hélas le très joli coup de
vladimir kramnik coûts qui avait
complètement échappé à nos commentateurs
français c'est-à-dire robert fontaine et
toi ouais et moi oui meilleure personne
n'avait vu la possibilité des blancs
c'est le coût 21 f4 voyez donc en fait
ouais ce cookie qui n'était pas attendue
parce qu'il affaiblit un peu la position
durable en mais d'un autre côté il a des
avantages parce que c'est le pion doublé
et il menace de pousser le pion à f/5
éventuellement et de 1,6 de dédoubler
ses pions et donc d'avoir un pur de plus
nette
d'autant plus que si on échange un de
ces trois pions et bédié et noir
commence à avoir un roi un peu ses
tripes et le roi commence à être faibles
aussi tout à fait dans quel cadre
extrêmement fort quand on a vu ce coup
on avait plus de doute
ici on savait que kasparov allait
commencer à souffrir ouais enfin quand
on a vu cette coupe parce qu'on savait
que s'il cramique le jouer c'est qu'il
avait vu quelque chose tout à fait en
plus j'ai toujours cet effet donc avalé
la magie du direct comme on peut on peut
on dire quelques mots ici oui c'est que
chaque fois qu'un joueur joue on pense
qu'il est mieux ouais et après le coup
d'un joueur voilà on voit beaucoup
d'idées on voit plein de choses on se
demande ce que va faire l'autre est
alors la suite la jolie plein de trouver
par kasparov qui joue d'amd 8 avec
l'idée quand même de ramener la dame du
côté roi parce qu'il faut déstabiliser
les cases noires c'est ça l'idée de
kasparov en jouant ce coup
f4 cramique récupère un peu de puissance
sur les cases noires puisque ce pion
contrôler les cases effectivement noir
et donc kasparov doit absolument avec
l'aide de son fils de saddam
contre-attaqué sur ces cases là du côté
droit du côté finalement du seul côté ou
cramique a des faiblesses
c'est vrai c'est vrai la dame d'éviter
la dame était mal placé toute façon il
faut qu'elles reviennent donc la vie en
h4
enfin le prépare l'arrivée à auch iv
avec cette menace échec perpétuelle sur
les cases g4 et f3 donc kasparov menace
de faire nul en quelques coups six
chroniques de faire un évidemment
tragique n'est pas d'accord il joue dame
c3 donc là il active saddam kramix c'est
ça a l'air d'être bien joué aussi
puisque saddam pour l'instant contrôle
très très jolie diagonale vers le roi
noir ça peut avoir un sens éventuelles
et puis cette dame va pouvoir revenir
aussi du côté roy soit en g3 son f3
éventuellement est donc protégée mais
sur mon arc et là incroyable
il s'est produit quelque chose
incroyable ici kasparov joffo baby et
propose nous propose nul alors donc ils
étaient sûrs qu'il allaient récupérer le
poste 4 propose nul ou pas on n'en est
pas sûr puisqu'on a que la vidéo mais
apparemment kasparov aurait proposé nul
ou alors il aurait murmuré il serait
mordu la langue on ne sait pas mais en
tout cas ils avaient vraiment l'air de
diarrhée chronique voilà c'est nul on
fait du jeu te propose nul tu es
d'accord on fait du machin ce qui paraît
curieux parce qu'en général quand on a
un pion de moins on n'est pas à même de
proposer nul non on est plutôt en train
d'attendre une proposition si voilà
pense que si c'est celui qui a le plus
qui en général propose là nul s'il en a
envie
parce qu'il peut jouer pour le gain ça
c'est plutôt là la règle
donc nous allons continuer fougue et
huit dames f3 des fourrures f4 damage 4
continue à attaquer le pion et la très
jolie constitue une chronique alors
qu'ils jouent eux 5 ha bah il n'a pas le
choix là il faut parce que sinon elle
perd le pen conception superbe c'est que
s'ils jouent f5 non mais c'est la
conception du coup f4 il est mat en page
2 et là on en voit l'idée de crâne hic c
est qu après abu chronique s'adapter en
font ainsi atteint 1,5 donc le suivant
complètement le fourbe et vite
voilà tu le fourbe et 8 et la casse
karpov et kasparov pardon décidément
doit absolument réagir le plus vite
possible parce que sinon kramnik menace
de se consolider au centre probablement
partout re 1 et ensuite éventuellement
tours 4 donc oui on également tour bien
et tourbe et sept autour d un tour mais
il ya beaucoup de menaces il ya beaucoup
de menaces des ménages
donc il faut contre attaque ils sont
quinze mois encore une fois donc à sport
joue le coup qu'il semblait au départ
assuré la nulle puisque effectivement
après par exemple ici qui on prend g5 et
bien évidemment fou prendre 5 est très
fort oui leur reprocher 5
à la limite je dirais dans parlons pas
puisque c'est une c'est une énorme faute
il ya effectivement il ya plusieurs
possibilités il faut prouver 5 qui a
aussi d'engranger 5 échecs et d'hommes
prendre cinq à dix fois aussi donc là
ici sur g5
l'idée c'est de casser ce duo de pions
voilà et donc on a bien l'impression
kasparov récupère son pion oui tout à
fait mais la thermique a vu que l'on il
ya vu plus loin il a vu tour un superbe
coup maintenant donc kasparov doit
échanger et dame doit prendre f4
s'efforcer dame préemption france des
kasparov a récupéré son pur - il va
faire nul facilement ses défauts de
couleurs opposées et en fait non
chronique j'ai eu six là faut prendre
obligé de prendre puisque la menace ses
pions preuve cet échec si le purifient
cette bouche
évidemment c'est eux cet échec avec
récupération de métaux et suit donc la
main ses recettes la menace ils vous
savez si ce qui fait dame qui fait
d'annoncé il ya également que trois sets
voilà donc de toute façon ici il faut
qu'on donc on rentre tout reprend et la
menace ici évidemment c'est un échec à
la découverte de la tour qui toujours
embêtant et le pion à 6 cette attaque
est donc pour par l'échec à la
découverte directeur du rocher cette
tour prend 1,6 million de plus en plus
en plus ça y est et pas facile quand
même parce que foot me reposer il faut
arriver à trouver une bonne solution
pour passer alors là aussi choses
importantes
kasparov et très mal autant il y aurait
ce cap minutes pour jouer dix coups à
peu près enfin peut-être un peu plus à
ce moment-là 7 7 8 minutes et on va voir
qui des ans il est très très mal autant
et c'est un facteur très important parce
que peut-être on peut annuler cette
finale mais il faut jouer extrêmement
précis qu'est-ce qu'on va dire la
conférence de presse qui va être archivé
bientôt sur canal web games que il
aurait pu faire nul mais on va voir
après comment ils comment ils pensaient
pouvoir avoir de bonnes chances de nul
en tout cas ici pour l'instant ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'il ya deux faiblesses
ya le pion à 4 qui est pas très bien
placé dans la mesure où le roi blanc
peut monter dessus avec roger de rouaf 3
et ainsi de suite et le pion à deux donc
ça fait deux facteurs difficiles à tenir
pour les noirs d'autant plus que le roi
n'est pas très n'est pas très bien placé
dans cette position donc c'est très
difficile pour les noirs tous rêvent
5-fu aux quatre kasparov et chroniques
joue au chat et la souris tour au sein
de rectoraux 5 et là on s'est demandé
est-ce qu'il fallait jouer de f3 ou pas
oui on avait l'impression que c'était
mieux d'essayer de jouer tour à 4 et
ensuite orages et de f3 mais le crâne il
joue en f3 trawick joseph 3 quand même
effectivement grandes conceptions un
coup tactique et stratégique à la fois
c'est très très bien joué on va voir
pourquoi tout de suite kasparov se
réorganise tour cette chronique c'est
l'heure d'avancer ses pions on n'a pas
de temps à perdre a donc c'est
déstabiliser l'adversaire sur les dames
et là la faute de kasparov à la faute
mentionné par kasparov tour à 7
kasparov dit dans cette position qu'il
aurait dû jouer fou e5 éventuellement
suivie par tous est donc sauvé quatre
échecs à suivre sur la conférence de
presse qui archive et à partir demain de
demain matin et qui donc sera de la même
date que cette émission tour à sept
tours b 6
la cram ligue des champions de loin sur
la 4e manger on voit que la tour de
kasparov et pour l'instant museler très
mal placé trouvé quatre tours 17
kasparov ne supporte pas l'inactivité
chronique ne peut pas jouer à 5
parce que il y aurait un problème
technique dans cette position c'est
qu'il y à tour d un échec
roger 2 et tour un point qui attaquent
le pion qui menacerait de reprendre le
pion assez rapidement donc qui pose des
problèmes donc comme nick ne se presse
pas il n'est pas pressé d'avancer ses
pions dans cette position après tour 17
il joue orages et deux mois j'ai deux et
il veut d'abord mettre le roi henri iii
et ensuite avancé des pions voyage 3
éventuellement g4 même si les noirs le
laisse faire et ça va expliquer la suite
d'ailleurs puisque ont déniché tour d2
échec 3-3 kasparov joue quel sport dit
stop h5 puisqu'il veut pas que le roi
évidemment ça petit trot et la trame
nicloux tour b5 la saq
on sait être très très dur pour kasparov
je pense que ces perdants ici puisque à
mon avis a plus de solution l'a déjà
s'il faut bouge le pion h5 est perdu
voilà ça c'est pas possible donc garijo
drive 6 à 5
donc menace à six à sept à huit dames
oui puisque la calamité contrôlée par ce
fou de 4 donc il faut faire attention de
la boucherie à 5 tours à deux tours b 6
échecs
hélas sa menace il faut faire attention
puisque tombé six échecs pour quoi faire
mais c'est pour pousser probablement à 5
à 6 et le roi n'en il faut qu'il fasse
attention parce que si le roi vit à
angers 5
évidemment c'est l'erreur c'est la gaffe
c'est la cas yade c'est la cagade c'est
tour j'ai six échecs et mat
chez keynote pourquoi évidemment parce
que le roi d'appliquer ou alors tout
simplement donc le roi déjà ne peut pas
jouer sur cette case
il peut éventuellement jouer en effet 7
ou angers7
on excepte les possibles aussi mais là
aussi il ya une grosse cagade c'est
évidemment des cinq fourchette fou des
cinq échecs au revoir et la tour à deux
étant prises et donc perdu au coude au
coup suivant reste donc angers7
éventuellement une case qui al'air
possible mais la star of choisi c'est la
seule case ici c'est clairement la seule
case encore tenable bien qu'après à 6 la
position 2k sports soit évidemment quasi
désespérée puisque le pion quand même
commence à faire très peur
ouais la corruption commence à faire
très peur kasparov choisi dans cette
position le court house est hélas cry
like chronique je fous des cinq
tranquille fou des cinq attaques la
torah de menaces
mais ce qui suit dans la partie c'est à
dire qu'après tout reprend 1 à 5 dont il
a parlé il abandonne tout qu'un trader
est une possibilité il y à tour aux six
échecs toro 6 échec au roi 17 17 tour
profane et la roi décide seul coup pour
récupérer la pièce et après tu te prends
h5 échanges rock récupération du fou les
blancs reprennent la tour et le roi
ensuite prendre un tour et là après roy
g4 on voit que les noirs pourront pas
arrêter le pion h4 sa randonnée ils vont
perdre le plus efficace voilà toute
façon il perdrait tous les vieux donc
c'est terminé il y avait une autre
possibilité de tentative de défense
bardon sait on est à londres donc il
fait froid et donc on a tendance à 100
rue mais ce n'est pas surprenant food et
il ya l'autre possibilité c'est tours 2
il faut protéger le fou évidemment
défendre le fou mais là il y a le coup
de massue à 6 tout simplement à 6 menace
à 7,7 et habite et surtout des quatre se
fout des quatre cas l'air de 6 laptop
bouche bée encontre l'assiette mais non
m'aideront à 7 quand même
et ici c'est tout simplement terminé
s'est terminée puisque six tours à 2 la
tour est perdu
si foudre un tour et b dames et on gagne
facilement donc kasparov abandonne très
logiquement dans cette position après sa
gaffe sa mini gav puisqu'on peut
supposer que sa position était perdante
travnik prend l'avantagé donc très belle
réalisation kramnik c'est très chaud
kasparov doit pas être content du tout
donc je dis ça va être très intéressant
puisqu'on va voir si karpov continuer a
essayé d'insister sur e4 kasparov et
kasparov s'est dit quoi il va ressembler
dans ton de karpov
donc si kolarov continue d'assister avec
eux quatre
et dans ce cas-là voir si kramnik essaie
de tenir la position avec la même
variante aulas et oui c'est très
chouette il rejouer la fameuse
berlinoise
eh bien on le saura vraisemblablement
jeudi cela ou le match commence parce
qu'on va voir les variations maintenant
des joueurs sur les variantes qui sont
préparés voilà donc on se donne
rendez-vous à jeudi poursuivre dans le
direct à partir donc de 15h en us 16h
heure française suivi donc de la
conférence de presse et puis des
émissions anglais et français
jeudi après midi évidemment dès demain
matin ses émissions sont archivés vous
pouvez donc consulter la conférence de
presse d'aujourd'hui ainsi que le résumé
anglais et français on vous dit à demain
oui le fait est que juste un petit
détail quand les émissions seront
archivés et bien c'est que vous pourrez
les voir voilà c'est terminé pour ce
soir et à jeudi vers 6